and heckling cookies hey Inez and these
cookies that's right that's how you
remember it that's how I remember and
have cuz you're sweet like a cookie she
isn't that sweet like a cookie I met her
and she lied about what who she was
what'd she say
I actually want to go see a creme Bailey
Rae and jimmy kimmel you could have been
with her too I'm hoping this [ __ ] up
later no I don't do that man - Cyrus by
I don't know I don't you flip you know
what my girlfriend she laughed at me cuz
she went to my room back in Lakewood
uh-huh and I have like I still have my
little cream Bailey current cream Bailey
Rae is a career in Corinne I know her
[ __ ] I don't know maybe I don't know
I don't know but I have like a shrine
like posters in the corner of like all
the pictures I took with her and she's
like oh my god like it see and like it's
like yeah why can't I not have a crush
on ya Corinne because she's jealous dude
it's because she's also a musician and
you don't have any [ __ ] pictures of
her like that with her [ __ ] music
that's true man [ __ ] an accent Corinne
Bailey Rae man you could have had a nice
date we thought you gonna say gonna
bring that up later somewhere a bit
later like in five seconds you better
tell you about the critic barely raised
you about the shame Corinne if you're
watching this which I guarantee you're
not because you look like you're a
classy intelligible human being I will
say this though this man he's taken now
but back then he should have taken his
chance with you he should have asked you
out on a date and he didn't and he liked
you too he loved you he still loves you
I do what happened you tell that
[ __ ] so um I was on a lunch run
at work and I went tomorrow's this is
what I first started working for this
entertainment lawyer in West Hollywood
and he's like what do you want for lunch
I'm like I don't know it on this area
like yeah let's go to I don't know five
guys he's like no let's go tomorrow it's
pretty fancy over there and you could
check out but it's not pop Mitchell
anyways that's not important anyways I
I'm going there to pick up an order and
the second I get out of my car like
she's probably like 50 feet away I just
see the back of her head I do see Acker
you know black hair I'm like
that's creamy larae without a doubt I
know that's cream valerio turn around
she had a guitar [ __ ] bad yeah I was
like SR started walking closer and
closer and closer and then I look side I
to her and it was her I'm like oh [ __ ]
cool I go to the front desk go pay for
the lunch order for the office and
they're like oh we actually need to fill
one more order we forgot to put in your
you know to go so can't just hang out
for a couple of minutes am i cool so the
only seat that was available for me to
wait was right next to cream by Larry's
table and her I'm assuming as a
publicist and her manager yeah I think
she's in town recording her new album
that just came out was it called like
Green aphrodisiac or something like that
so I'm beautiful
something beautiful yeah it's always
beautiful
I get the hutzpah to say hey um I'm a
fan yeah we've actually met three times
I met you at the House of Blues I met
you at the Troubadour and I met you at
the for theater all coincidental stuff
and I met you actually for cuz Jimmy
Kimmel I know I'm in her four times and
then her friend was like oh see like
he's a Fed like he remembers you she is
like cool cool and uh they were I guess
they were recording at Capitol Records
Oh
and I was like oh and I just started
falling you Instagram you actually liked
my photo with Maxine like we're on top
of yeah you're on top of all you want to
Instagram no no she did not follow me
she liked one of my photos that's the
same [ __ ] to me especially yeah went
this is prefer shaven I got she broke a
thousand followers like she just was so
curious about the medium and she liked
it and she she finished my sentence
before I am told her what photo she
liked I was like you like my photos that
my Dutch I know and then he was like
look see your social media it's working
above us so I'm just there talking to
her is like oh you know we're recording
at Capitol Records
over there on was it vine yeah you're
right I don't know um so what would like
what are you doing I'm like uh I'm just
picking up lunch it's like Oh like you
should still like you were gonna eat
here I was like yeah I gotta go back to
work those like oh why did you tease
like eat a sandwich with to eat lunch
that's my [ __ ] dream dude you know
what that means
I mean she was interested in you I know
nobody [ __ ] looks at somebody says he
oh I just seat you either sandwich with
me nobody nobody has ever offered me to
sit down and have a sandwich with them
ever even fans I know I can't no I can't
separate cuz in the back of my mind I
knew about her her husband her husband
passed away yeah and I was like this may
sound a little sensitive it's gonna be
insensitive he's dead alright so listen
[ __ ] rector dude I understand but at
that point it's been quite a few years
when you met her it's been quite a last
few years a few years yeah yo homie rest
in peace man you had a very beautiful
life I heard you were musician as well
you were a jazz musician I heard he
plays some kind of jazzy ass instrument
and I'm pretty sure you guys had a
beautiful relationship rest in peace oh
but what I'm trying but what I'm trying
to say is you dead now and it was not
yeah he would he would've been haunting
you like that [ __ ] doing on big mouth
[Laughter]
but you uh you did not have lunch with
her and I have lunch with her I went
back to work like I'm back to work and
then I sent you the picture and like I'm
so disappointed in your newest artist I
was so [ __ ] disappointed if Corinne
Bailey Rae said hey I want you to go
home right now
I want you to get a wet towel right I
want you to soak it in butane and I want
you to like your [ __ ] neighbors
children on fire oh I would have done it
in a second you got to be honest I would
too well that's difficult
[ __ ] hate them is exactly how you
want to get into stories
okay that's another episode man if I can
don't spit no don't spray the rod yeah
I'll tell you that right now I'll kick
those kids in the [ __ ] face I love
you kids no you guys have an ability to
change anybody can change but not those
kids [ __ ] them
they're terrible you had a chance with
cranberry rain you didn't [ __ ] take
it yeah and that's why I became an actor
exactly full circle so right now are you
argue if you okay this is what I really
want to ask just because I've had a
couple of friends come up to me they
asked me why okay so how do I become an
actor and I can't really explain that
process and my brother so what would you
tell somebody will be the first steps
man the first a class